Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia says his
country doesn't owe a merica a cent in
unpaid weapons bills his remark was a
response to Donald Trump
who'd issued a warning to the Gulf
Kingdom we protect Saudi Arabia would
you say they're rich and I love the King
King Salman but I said King we're
protecting you you might not be there
for two weeks without us you have to pay
for your military actually we will pay
nothing for our security we believe that
all the armaments we have from the
United States of America are paid for
they're not free armaments we have to
accept that any friend will say good
things and bad things you cannot have
friends saying 100% good things about
you even in your family you have some
misunderstandings so we put that in that
category we adds traditional foe Iran
also weighed in with Tehran's top
diplomat tweeting that it's a delusion
to think that one can outsource security
adding also that the Saudis should focus
on building regional bridges now Saudi
Arabia and the u.s. have been close
allies for decades but in the last 10
years
Washington has sold the country three
hundred and fifty billion dollars worth
of weapons other business deals between
the two powers are said to be worth tens
of billions Patrick Henningsen the
founder of the news website 21st century
wire a believes Iran is simply trying to
convince Saudi Arabia it doesn't need
America's protection the question is who
is the u.s. protecting Saudi from
they're not going to be invaded or
overthrown by Styria or Yemen even there
is no country strong enough to topple
Saudi Arabia except for the United
States so that's how our protection
racket works
you pay the Mafia and the Mafia allows
you to run your business and what Iran
is doing by reaching out is basically
exposing the hypocrisy saying look
you're you're under a protectionist
arrangement or a protection racket
arrangement from the United States and
so why don't you think about a
collective regional security arrangement
that's in everybody's interests and so
and not to be a client state of
Washington
you